Film Courage: We had another question come
in [from the viewers].
It’s much more light-hearted than our previous
conversation.
Bing Liu, filmmaker of MINDING THE GAP documentary:
What’s their name?
Film Courage: His name is Nafis Mustafa.
Bing: Okay, I’m just hoping for another
ZombieDude64.
Film Courage: Nafis, he has commented before
and he’s great.
He writes “What would be your core advice
to aspiring filmmaker?”
So let’s supposed somebody is 14 again [like
Bing’s story] but not with mini-DV (in the
current form).
This time they have a 4k camera or another
amazing camera that they’re currently using.
Bing: Do it for the love, you know?
When I was growing up in Rockford [Illinois,
where much of MINDING THE GAP is filmed] being
a filmmaker was just such a realistic thing.
I was just doing it for the love, right?
I was emulating things, it felt good to be
creative.
But in terms of making a film, these things
take years.
So don’t pick something that you’re not
truly passionate about.
Pick something that you care about more than
just making a film.
And I think everyone because of their personal
experience, because of where they come from,
because of the way they think, everyone has
at least one story within themselves that
only they can tell and nobody else can tell.
I think people should honor and respect that
for themselves and I don’t just mean making
a personal film about themselves.
We really need to sort of have understanding
across many different aisles and lines that
seem a little bit more highlighted these days,
lines of division.
Film Courage: Absolutely.
What did you used to film the movie [MINDING
THE GAP on Hulu] with from the mini-DV camera
to there were other shots that definitely
were not mini-DV?
Bing: I consider all that stuff archival.
But so filming it with three different DSLRs
and c300.